[Music]
my name is welcome back to the moon
it's my name
I am supporting let's just keep going we
just entered the lighthouse and we're
back in the Grandpa's memory good song
it right here we need two more boss it's
a lot of girls I need two more balls but
about time you got here
Alice thought you fell off a cliff why
were you doing enjoying the scenery or
does any luck here via clock huge
dinosaur egg by of course that's pretty
big alike huh this place looks pretty
empty it's a lighthouse
why do you expect he's always gotta be a
smartass well they're both gotta be
smaller
anyway I'll catch you on the other side
have fun we breaking the barrier for
yourself but what do I have to do
alright ha oh I get I guess we got some
alone time with John huh I put the ball
what is going on just [ __ ] them all in
there you got all the balls girl you got
all the balls you need let's go prepare
what ok well oh it's a side AK ideal
shows the minimum of moves the moment
that can be completed all right so three
moves oh I got it easy
yay
side up where's that sorry I don't
platypus that's what it is alright can
we talk to John let's activate the
Psyduck No
all right we're in another memory oh oh
now we're beginning to go a little
younger I love the Sun in this game it's
just enough I'm in just enough I don't
know what [ __ ] was after we pay for
your operation we'll have just enough
left for it so don't you worry white lie
that's what do you call it right no I'm
sure we can just stop it
sorry this is serious I don't like it
when you lie it sounds like my
girlfriend hmm sorry Irie I calculate
our finances and I know it said what
it's like why do you try to convince me
against my will
we did it money for your medical bills
River I understand it Anja means a lot
to you but this this is just too much I
mean she she isn't even do you know what
makes me happy Johnny what do you I
guess he doesn't well I do I just hope
you can help me with it forever
that is so say when the papers for my
treatments get here I will not sign them
what you do with our money is up to you
but if you would grant my wish I want
you to use it to finish building that
house and then for every day that you
live there I want you to watch over her
visit her speak to her comfort her
I don't want her to be alone anymore
and what about you happy I'll be happy
Johnny yeah
I made this
tell me what it is what just tell me
what it is
[Music]
it's a rabbit it's like all the others
you make what else is that the color one
yeah it is it's made of paper what else
it's bodies yellow and the rest is blue
good what else she's really annoying no
offense
look River I wrote a song it's for you
Wow they make each other a nice thing
okay not like oh how sweet
alright well would you like to hear it
yes should awkward conversation I didn't
have you didn't have to bring the piano
here for this I can hear you just fine
with the door open it's really sad
really sad
all right I know which song it is it's
called for all right so sleigh why so
cliche it's just a placeholder
[Music]
who is this anya than they were talking
about if she's so important wouldn't we
have seen her in his late memories I
guess hit it I got you didn't keep your
promise after all unless I let walk
never mind
hey that's the same song the kids were
playing earlier huh I guess he taught
them
you know what I'm too manly for this
that's right
you're totally too manly for this I'm I
already got my memory link so you want
to catch a quick ride and look around
yourself I think we are good to go
let's disco
[Music]
backing down all right now we are in
this I guess 50 50 40 40 fine
no I don't know all right we're going up
nice jump you to halt any [ __ ] huh huh
look what we have here what do we have
here
[Laughter]
oh he bad it's the house they were
talking about I bet they saw this cliff
and thought it was not danger enough
without people living on I don't know
about dr. watts to be fully honest but
okay let's see what he's doing now
Johnny how's it going Johnny you're a
good man building all that stuff for a
girl am girl Nick called a nice and said
I should come
I brought you pick it olive they are
favored right they're not I heard about
really will she be okay
her illness was just diagnosed in
late-stage fortunately it's treatable
but the medical bills well maybe you
shouldn't buy a oh we can't afford to
finish its middle to building this house
is about we can barely afford to pay for
her treatment I'm just relieved that
she'll be okay but you don't know much
about this how much this place means to
her she's going to be heartbroken I'd
help but Ted and I have barely getting
by since the market crashed
what are you going to do now how about
not building the house I'm going to tell
her that we can make it well he's got to
get money somehow to be released - I'm
going to tell her that we can afford
everything oh I don't want her to do
anything crazy
you shouldn't lie - but he only does it
because he loves her she don't
understand about it if she found out I'm
not sure which she'd choose so what if
she chooses not to save herself for the
sake of this place and so be it it's
what she really wants
I really dislike when you neurotypical
think you know what's best for others I
hate when you called me that easy
that's right easy you don't call him a
neurotic or prickle do you think this is
all about her
what about me Isabelle after all these
years I'm not allowed to be selfish even
once
I don't want to be alone as a man ah I'm
not going to let her die
that's arrogant I don't God what are you
doing I'm going to pick something from
this cliff to bring back to her I
it'll at least give her some comfort
that doesn't make you what you're doing
any less wrong girl Nick wanted me to
this is what is that
he said it's called everything all right
everything's all right
everything's gonna be all right it isn't
yeah oh no he did add oh no your dog
don't you dog he's just walking away as
a name that is not good you shouted big
fighting well let's see what this is
about
that gave us a point this should call
him no oh that's what triggers it all
right
maybe this little car should do
something oh I should holy [ __ ] the car
all right let's check inside inside with
something that's interesting I didn't
inside South had a value but you never
know these days let's check this out
thank you
it makes you want to eat more I don't
even like Nutella Night Watch I love
Nutella ah there were two balls crossing
a bridge that is that's obvious I can't
believe I thought or not didn't think of
that
all right let's go back in time back in
time back in time like when we're back
in camp charge that I left what balls
[ __ ] yeah
prepare prepare the olives oh and all
right
[ __ ] three moves I already [ __ ] it up
actually no I didn't I got it tinea
spirits solves the Picard olives that
looks pretty gross but hey are we going
all right I I received no to pick an
olive actually I wonder if these old
things we collect will make sense we
have the PI reply I mean the umbrella
I'm sorry I'm Swedish
and the Orleans and platypus I think ah
how convenient
so are you guys going party huh this is
when they're planning the building
prolly yeah because luckily starting
just a few months it's a bit of a
squeeze we had to split the payment but
what with financing we'll make it do how
wonderful having a dream house bill it's
such a beautiful set
you had your wedding at 9:00 at that
lighthouse in the earlier oh that's our
romantic
oh that's years ago didn't you that's
not it
oh that's special about it we all have a
long history with that place well it's
good to have some good news that I get
together for once
cheers and congratulations yet oh hey
Cheers
ah they were starting off so good and
then it all went went to hell that is so
sad
be right back I'm be right BRB I'm gonna
get some fresh air
me too that's girls code for trash talk
but men and this is men's chance to talk
about vagina and help buddy sharpener
Wow passionate ho know how hard it is to
get across a fierce city nowaday that
rebus still so quiet huh ah she's
actually been talking about a home and
with Isabel I guess she's just I used to
you ha ha ha sound about a guy here huh
you are oh hey so did you tell the river
that thing from back then huh I did what
thing so how does she take it
for the most part she took it well but
something bugs me what happened uh ever
since the accident she's been making
these strange rabbits alright
origami rabbits yes lots of them
ha I used to fall our agama animals for
my daughter all the time
what's wrong with that I don't think
it's the same thing she's been doing
nothing but make the same rabbit day in
and day out our house is literally
filled with them now I didn't there's a
bell say something like that it's a
common trait with rivers condition yes
but something doesn't feel right this
time when I asked her about it she never
answers instead she gets this distant
look in her eyes it's almost our ship
she wants something from me oh he
doesn't understand
and the strange thing is I feel like
there's something I oh yes you don't
understand
have you asked this about yes she said
she talked to her about it but God
nothing you don't understand I don't
understand either but it doesn't matter
girls are complicated
well subtle dad wondering quiet but I'll
tell you this I known you since middle
school and you're notorious for
overthinking you're probably just
imagining things there's no need to get
too worked up usually when someone says
that something always wrong but I'll
give you the benefit of that you're
probably right probably
I'm always right John let's squeeze that
bottle Ella I'm always right oh all
right white so even he himself never
knew what was that without rabbit forgot
about just stupid rabbits we got bigger
Brahmans
it's a confide memory and there are no
Momentis anyway
don't worry we'll probably draw one out
of em huh leave it to me
I just gotta give the bottom that quick
visit come on dude
all right let's go to the bar down there
hey there
would you like anything hey solo I get a
drink hey y'all could I got a bottle of
pick it all of it
oh sure - your credit check I'm sorry we
don't take checks
oh just spread it on my tablet wait does
that mean you don't have any money
maybe you're so getting reset oh he
resets them alright hey there could I
get you anything
hello hello ah
can I get you a bottle can I get a
bottle of the Holly please sherry cash
or credit just put it on my tab I feel
like spending big today oh thank you see
here here are your pick it on it
thanks bro you'll be getting an enormous
sition [ __ ] thank you sir
you're such an ass Neil listen uh girl
lighten up your vajayjay - come on girl
all right I'll talk to more people
there's one up we can't why is that a
bottle of big Holland
oh yeah you're a fan of Oliver's how can
you be a fellow of olive lover
indeed I am just got a fresh ball of
myself in fact mind if I join you
sure why don't you grab a seat well well
down a bottle together
yeah that sounds swell just swell hey
rod this a little taste elimination now
what
Oh Neal I don't think I feel like it do
it I'm so gonna get you back for this
what is going on right now oh I get it
he hates the olives
okay so that's how we got our first
toaster you okay dark yes I'm just
savoring the amazingness of all right
they're wonderful aren't I
yeah I just don't can't understand how
anyone could find these things
disgusting yeah take your time we've got
two bottles left
oh that gives us one so I said hey
that's not right and they totally are
great for dr. Watts you gotta listen to
this and you know what else is wrong
with society today man just yeah I
actually got it right here why may I see
it
okay here it has tetanus and freaks find
an a dear Lord how are the olives Neal
oh shut your mouth shut your mouth girl
shut out but I detected a memento
let's do a save and the next episode we
go back in time bro but like if you
enjoyed subscribe to come to earth today
[Music]
and I have no idea how the monster will
look like that kind of bothers me a
little bit
hey bench how you doing hey honey I
didn't know benches talk it's new
all right cut because cherish talking's
not got there we go no way to run
nowhere to run nowhere to hide I could
never sleep at night what are you doing